eita rated look what's that mean
function yes good system so we'll leave
that as the headache
Oh a little subheading is there's
another name but we're gonna have a look
at today it also called a dynamic
sequences and you'll see why now remind
me again what topic are we about linear
medicine specifically fractals most
recently right and we spent all this
time looking at you know we shapes that
like this or triangles or angles and
we've kinds of shapes are very
time-consuming sorts of shapes okay now
we've been approaching fractals in a
geometric way which makes sense right
because what was that definition of a
fractal okay so let's try to boil it
down so I gave you like a full long
sentence mean right but it's kind of
like a shape with a a we'd special kind
of scale symmetry I think that's the
most important idea that we can boil
down right you zoom in zoom in and you
find the same kind of shape over and
over again right and this kind of shape
happens in real life like rivers
galaxies
now we've been approaching it from a
geometric point of view that's what
you've been doing as I said we were
doing drawings and I was like bison is
trisect that etc today we're gonna
purchase a fractal idea but in a way you
very much wouldn't expect them does it
look obvious at all
Bailey rather than geometric and
algebraic approach okay now I just want
you to keep this in the back of your
mind like this is kind of where your
hair okay because for a long time as we
look at these kinds of things whatever
they are it won't be obvious that we're
thinking of fractals at all okay so just
keep that as the context okay yeah let's
look at this idea here kind of practice
probably the the easy study in here that
you know about there is a function what
is a function
okay give me an example of a function
yeah yeah good okay so a function is now
there's lots of different ways to say
this I'm gonna take that as a starting
point
right there's kind of like an equation
or an expression right or if you like or
even more generally speaking a rule is a
rule that you put a value in and you get
something yet do you want to answer
these
okay so yeah you're starting to get
really specific I'm gonna try and keep
it to overall right so we said it's a
rule or an equation or depression
that's no here's the important phrase
that map's one value to another okay and
you know tons of these right so because
they're all functions we tend to denote
them like this f4 function of X right so
we're gonna put a value into this right
and then they're depending on what
happens over here you'll get some other
value right so simple example okay X
plus 1
okay this is a function it takes one
value and will map it to another so we
would write you know for instance f of 0
it matches to it maps to 1 right so 0 1
are mapped to each other okay or I could
say any value my life f of negative 100
it's gonna map - okay so you're getting
all these pairs right you see what's
going on so we know what function is
right but an iterative function says now
don't just do this once what was the
idea of iterations remember what we
worked out a definition it didn't wait
what was its rating about good it's not
this repeated process and we thought
about that geometrically right it's like
you know take something and then divided
up and then divide what you've got off
again and so on right so we can apply
this person is not just geometrically
but I directly that's it
ok here you go let's think of this let's
come back to this guy so if I treat this
as not just a function but an iterated
function system ok we start with okay
well some is zero again cuz that tends
to be the place where we start right and
you get one but then you put it again
right so now I'm going to iterate ok
and in this case so I'm getting these
numbers one two you can talk about the
next movie it's really four so this
particular sequence that I get out it's
called a dynamic sequence changing this
particular dynamic sequence that we get
out of this
in function system we give these a name
the sequence this is the sequence of or
counting numbers or natural numbers if
you like
now the pretty boring kind of sequence
okay so let's have a look at some more
interesting ones I'll leave that one bit
per second let's have a look at now
gentlemen plus or minus with all right
now you might think what this is is that
really all that more much more
interesting in the previous one and I'm
gonna suggest that it will be yeah can
you what well let's have a look shall we
now remember beside the euro our
function is you put values in and then
you get that it's out and it already
means do it over and over again
okay so again it will start cero we're
pretty much always going to start at
zero okay so what are you going to get
okay what so you're like right it starts
off pretty boring okay now I take this
value and I get right again so you get
an F of one okay so now when I put one
in here I'm gonna get two times 1 plus 1
which is 3 okay odd numbers so far right
iterate again okay so now I'm gonna go F
of 3 okay so it's 2 times 3 plus 1 still
an odd number but I missed one hammer 9
let's go again iterate again so f of 7
right is going to be 2 times 7 14 plus
once 15 ok can you keep going tell me
what to do next
1 3 7 15 oh absolutely they really can't
you tell I hope so look engaged this is
fragile sir
well we're getting there we're not quite
there yet but we will this they're
getting us a good Hill got my apologies
so that's it hold up all that time
that's right I'll be here until 6:00
yeah Mike next week you might have to be
the best thank you
yeah there you go
see it's all right sorry where were we
now I'm going to stop writing all these
because you can see I'm just gonna start
to write the sequence out okay so the 1
3 7 15 what's next eww add 1 ok w add 1
ah
are you starting to recognize what these
numbers are the next one's going to be a
hundred 27 the neck once Nick's was
going 250 511 a thousand and 23 are
people recognizing them yet now have a
look now this is interesting we kind of
predict it and it wasn't a bad
prediction we pretty did this would give
us odd numbers and has given us numbers
but it hasn't given us something the odd
numbers why not
it's because if I just took successive
values of X if I didn't F 1 F 2 F 3 and
4 and 5 and so on that would give me the
odd numbers which is great but I haven't
done that have I I have generated all
right so we're trying to wrap our head
around this process right which is
eventually gonna lead us somewhere like
this mysteriously ok algebra geometry
just too much the same for exercise so
what are these numbers these numbers
they are always one less than a power of
2 I'm just a bit an audio message on
that top zero right so if you add 1 to
all of these numbers you'll get 1 2 4 8
16 32 64 128 all the power tooth ok so
if you like you could say it kind of
like this here's a way there
but let's say the eighth turn right turn
and okay it's kind of equal to a power
of two minus one and this is any
important sequence just like this one is
it important secrets but it's a bit more
boring this sequence that we've just
generated here is called the Mersenne
sequence unsurprisingly named after a
guy named Sam okay now yeah this one
that's right now some important things
to note yeah of this machine guy he did
a lot of important things particularly
to do with prime numbers in fact some of
these not all of them some of these are
prime can you see some of them are prime
the not all which one surprise 0 prime
yeah 0 is kind of weird he's standing in
a corner it does doesn't have any to do
there one else is any classes over one
prime 1 1 copy Friday's not a prime
right I could if you by the way um later
on we have a double so we see how it
goes I don't know how many of you learnt
one isn't prime because and then and
then what was the reason they got
supplied it there's a very important
logical reason and it's bigger than the
two factors thing even that's a good
reason there's a very important logical
reason why one can't be prime if one was
prior it would break the University I'll
let you think three yes
one plus two plus seven years beforehand
and so not it works like doesn't it I
think it is point 255 clearly not grown
okay I don't know what stuff to happen
okay but is he put a theme right these
Prime's in here and there are there are
lots more of this they called Mersenne
primes okay now we're gonna spend a lot
of time with you those later on but I
just thought to mention that says here's
the sequence
okay so so now you are you're introduced
to this idea of an iterated function
system okay the idea of taking a
function and then and then go over and
over again the rapini okay but these two
a pretty pedestrian they're pretty
simple
okay so I'm going to give you a bit of a
harder one just give me a second while I
how much can I rub off they're all off
everything second planet